what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and we just watched the
first episode of miss marvel now right
away i wanna know what you think about
this series so far in the comments down
below what did you think of the first
episode let me know now miss marvel is
going to be an important disney plus
series because it is going to lead up to
the marvels which is really just captain
marvel 2. but important to watch so
let's talk about who miss marvel is and
what to expect from the show and i'm
really excited to announce that i have
signed a partnership with elgato they
have made my studio look a million times
better so big thank you to them and also
if you're curious to the equipment that
i got you can check that out and the
link down below now let's dive into the
first episode of miss marvel and of
course if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos now right off the
bat we have to talk about how the
opening sequence for miss marvel episode
1 is a youtube video in the mcu kamala
khan is a youtuber talking about her
passion superheroes which i can
definitely relate to because that's what
i do and it also makes you wonder what
videos the people over at marvel studios
are watching now there are a ton of
easter eggs in the first episode heck
the opening scene alone has probably 30
different easter eggs they recap the
entire final fight from avengers end
game and it's important to note that in
kamala's eyes captain marvel is actually
the reason that the avengers defeated
thanos now there is something very very
important that we have to go over here
and that is the complete change to
kamala khan's origin story now for those
of you who were hoping to see the
inhumans well sorry obviously we did not
get that and miss marvel is not an
inhuman in the mcu now besides that fact
besides the change to her origin this
might actually be the most comic
accurate episode from marvel studios
that we've gotten so far out of all the
disney plush shows now in the comics
when she first debuts she is much like
when she debuts in episode one she is a
huge fan of superheroes specifically
captain marvel so she's an incredibly
relatable character to all of us because
we are all fans of superheroes now with
the exception of no inhumans or terrigen
mist komala's origin is kind of similar
in the comics except for these bands
which are extremely important and we're
about to get to but in the comics kamala
wants to go to a party against her
parents wishes so against their wishes
she actually goes to the jersey
waterfront unfortunately there she runs
into zoey who of course was introduced
in this episode as well and her
boyfriend josh and they pick on her and
ostracize her miserable she starts to
head home when all of a sudden the city
is clouded in terrigen mist she then
goes unconscious in her terrigen cocoon
where she sees a vision of her three
favorite superheroes captain america
iron man and of course captain marvel
and what's interesting is that in this
vision the heroes actually scold her
they tell her that she's disobedient and
they ask her what she wants in life in
which kamala tells them she wants to be
more like captain marvel a beautiful and
awesome butt-kicking woman who was also
less complicated now when kamala emerges
she has shape-shifting powers and
originally she actually looks like
captain marvel it's also important to
note that in the comics at least kamala
khan also finds out that she has healing
abilities she can heal herself by
reverting back to her normal form but
after the terrigen miss clears and after
kamala calms down after finding out that
she has polymorph abilities she
eventually makes her way back to the
jersey waterfront in which she sees
zoe's drunken boyfriend josh
accidentally cause her to fall into the
river in which kamala turns into miss
marvel and actually saved zoe and this
is pretty much what happened in the
first episode at avengers con kamala
discovers that she has these new powers
thanks to the band that she is wearing
and she saves zoe she also caused
everything to happen and put her in
danger in the first place but we won't
talk about that whoops but here's where
things get very very interesting because
obviously she is not an inhuman in the
show and she gets her powers from the
band that she puts on that her
grandmother gave her now it seemed very
obvious that her grandmother wanted her
to have this band and it seems very
obvious as well that her mother knows
exactly what this band is and did not
want kamala to have it this makes you
wonder if kamala's grandmother once upon
a time was actually a superhero and i'm
definitely thinking this is going to be
one of the key factors of kamala khan's
story in these six episodes which we'll
find out later but going back to the
bands if you saw my breakdown of the
very first trailer that we got for miss
marvel you know that i actually think
that these are the nega bands now the
nega bands in the comics are actually
two bracelets so perhaps there is
another one out there but they are an
ancient cree relic that have been around
for a millennia but that connection to
the cree i think is extremely important
here because we know that miss marvel is
going to lead into the marvels captain
of marvel 2 and what did the first
captain marvel movie explore the scroll
and the cree this leads me to believe
that this really could be a mega band
now i'm not sure if there are going to
be two or just one in the mcu but either
way i believe that's what it is plus
secret invasion is coming up and i think
we're gonna find out that some scroll
and some cree have actually been on
earth a lot longer than we think and
that could explain how kamala's
grandmother got the band in the first
place now in the comics what the nega
bands do is transform mental energy into
physical energy and based off of the
first episode and what we've seen in the
trailers it sure does seem like that's
what kamala's powers are her thinking
something and then it manifesting
through the power of the bracelet plus
not to mention she does say that the
power feels cosmic and sadly i'm
assuming they're not talking about me
but cosmic energy which is where things
get a little bit more interesting you
see the bands were originally given by
the cree supreme intelligence who we saw
in the first captain marvel film to
captain marvel not captain marvel but
captain mar dash vel however the bands
then trapped him inside of the negative
zone which i believe we actually saw in
this episode as we see kamala puts on
the bracelet and then enters another
type of realm here which does kind of
seem like a negative zone now
fortunately for kamala she does not get
trapped inside but i'm assuming we'll
revisit this soon in a later episode but
i believe that this is how miss marvel
is going to connect to captain marvel in
the mcu the mega bands are extremely
powerful and as i mentioned they are
from the cree and captain marvel isn't
really a cree but hey she thought she
was for a very long time and eventually
in the comics the nega bands were used
to create a nega bomb in which under the
influence of the supreme intelligence
they sent to devastate cree space this
is how i believe miss marvel is going to
draw the attention of captain marvel i
think captain marvel has probably sensed
that somebody has put on the nega bands
if anything captain marvel has sensed
this cosmic energy coming from earth and
i definitely think this series ends with
captain marvel showing up and telling
kamala that perhaps these bands have
drawn some unwanted attention and some
people are coming and that's going to
lead to the events of the marvels so yes
the origin of how kamala khan got her
powers have been changed however her
powers are pretty much similar here
instead of her body simply expanding it
looks more like an energy expansion but
it still looks pretty dang cool and like
i said the series overall has provided
some pretty dang good easter eggs and
some pretty dang comic accurate scenes
for example the scene in the beginning
where we see kamala walk downstairs and
we see her family from the first time is
taken exactly from the comics she walks
down and her brother is praying and her
father says and this is word for word
from the comic amir if you don't stop
praying long enough to put some food in
your mouth one day you will starve to
death in which in the show amir says may
allah forgive you one day and in the
comics he says may allah forgive you abu
in which in arabic abu means father of
so this scene was taken right from the
comics almost word for word exactly
which i personally really love that
combined with all the other awesome
easter eggs like the big little me a
scott lang interview about ant-man
podcast the fact that avengers con is
held at camp lehigh which is the new
jersey base where steve rogers trained
we also saw it in captain america the
winter soldier when natasha and steve
both went back to it then of course in
avengers in-game cap and tony went back
to it in 1970. plus not to mention at
avengers con you see a bunch of
different cosplayers as a bunch of
different superheroes and we do have a
tribute to natasha and tony so overall
in the first episode there were a lot of
really cool things that we saw and i do
think that this band that kamala has is
linked to the crease somehow and that is
how captain marvel comes into kamala
khan's life but let me know your best
theories about this in the comments down
below and let me know what your favorite
easter egg of episode 1 of miss marvel
was don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof